the outbreak is still growing
dramatically with 60 more cases reported
across the u.s. the CDC says now at
least 940 measles cases have been
reported across 26 states earlier this
month the case was discovered at an
airport dallas-fort Worth International
one of the busiest in the world
well malenky is at Newark Liberty
International Airport another busy one
and where another case of measles was
recently reported molo what's the danger
at an airport well Toni as we know
airports are high transit areas and the
CDC tells us that the measles virus can
linger in the air for up to two hours
which is actually pretty normal for most
airborne viruses but it's the attack
rate that's incredibly high if you have
the measles on average you'll infect up
to 18 people now compare that with the
flu where most people on average will
infect one to two people this summer
travelers may be dealing with more than
crowded airports the measles virus has
impacted at least four US airports so
far this year with reported exposures in
California New Jersey and most recently
Texas this is one of those situations
where somebody got you know exposed
overseas brought it back here Texas
Health officials addressed a recent
exposure at dallas-fort Worth
International Airport last week the
general public is not at risk only those
individuals who might have been at the
airport during that time and don't have
immunization against measles the CDC is
urging travelers to get vaccinated
especially international travelers who
could be at greater risk with travel
notices in five countries
dr. Nancy Messing a with the CDC
recommends fliers protect themselves
ahead of time when you actually arrive
at the airport to get on the airplane
it's too late to get your measles
vaccine these are high transit areas we
get very high volume of people coming
through from all over the world it is a
perfect place to have a great swapping
of that
period viruses a lot of hands a lot of
terms potentially yes dr. Kalyan babban
is chief wellness officer at George
Washington University's School of
Medicine and Health Sciences she says
when exposure occurs disease detectives
are deployed to investigate and look for
traces of the virus left behind who is
the individual who we know is that where
were they what stores do they go to at
restaurants did they go through we can
cover a lot of ground I guess in an
airport and then be able to really get
that information out so that everyone
who might be at risk is aware time
matters that's right I'm not gonna touch
my hand to my face and then I'm gonna
make sure I wash my hands dr. Bob on
showed us what millions of summer
travelers can do to steer clear of the
virus offering familiar but useful
advice keep your hands clean you can
carry a little bottle of your well
there's some surf account sanitizer with
you keep your hands washed if you're
going to be touching areas like the
kiosk to get your ticket but bond points
to security trays seat back tray tables
and arm rests as high contact areas to
be aware of passenger Kailen outrageous
self-described germaphobe sometimes
takes it a step further we've gone as
far as wearing gloves
our area and that sanitizer sprays gels
lotions about everything but we still
get sick so it's one of those things
where I just kind of say my prayers
about this now symptoms often start
simple enough high fever cough runny
nose the CDC says two doses of the
vaccine is about 97% effective one dose
Toni 93 percent effective molo what
about zero doses I've got a baby not yet
six months old
can't get a vaccine yet there are a lot
of other parents out there in the same
situation so what should parents do if
they're flying with a baby that has not
been vaccinated well Toni the CDC
guidance on this with regards to babies
is that babies between the ages of 6 and
11 months should have one dose of the
measles vaccine children 12 months or
older need at least two doses and those
two doses should be given at least 28
days apart children under six months old
as you mentioned know hard guidance on
the CDC about those kids but we've been
told
generally speaking anyone without a
vaccine planning to fly this summer is
putting themselves at risk Wow okay
question mark now over that summer
wedding I know it's your best friend I
know it's your college roommate and your
best friend but we may not be making it
sorry honey
maybe she can make it new and tricky
really tough decision
alright it's wedding or teddy wedding
kidding teddy moly we thank you again